[UPBEAT MUSIC]
Hi I'm Gemma Chan
and I play Sersi.
And I'm Richard Madden
and I play Ikaris.
I am Lauren Ridloff
and I play Makkari.
I'm Lea McHugh
and I play Sprite.
And I'm Kumail
Nanjiani and I play Kingo
in Marvel Studios' "Eternals."
Which member of
our cast is most
likely to stay up all night
watching Marvel Studios movies?
Kumail?
I would definitely say Kumail.
He's already labeled
himself as the "Marvel Geek."
KUMAIL NANJIANI: I've seen all
these movies multiple times
and I love watching
movies at night.
GEMMA CHAN: Who would
be most likely to give
the perfect take?
- That would be me.
What did you say?
Did you say you?
[LAUGHS]
Probably Angelina.
She was always very prepared.
Yeah, she's a pro.
Probably me and then Angie.
TRANSLATOR: Who's most likely
to laugh during a take?
I would probably say Salma.
She just laughs all
throughout the day.
LEA MCHUGH: Most
likely to nap on set.
Don or Karun.
Don?
Don could go and
have a nice nap.
East.
GEMMA CHAN: Most likely to
organize a hangout after work.
I suppose we have
to give that to Angie.
She threw us an--
Yeah.
--an amazing Halloween party.
She actually hosted different
gatherings for our family
to hang out together.
We went kite-flying, we had a
Halloween party, a movie night.
RICHARD MADDEN: Most likely
to break into song and dance.
It's got to be Kumail.
He's got the dance number.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]